tata welcome to the show and my first
question for you is
why haven't you played knight f3 earlier
i mean you can have this conversation
with alejandro he's been telling me to
do this for years
really
so why today
um well i mean i'm not having the most
inspiring tournament and we just had a
long conversation about
this tournament my chest and he was just
like you have to play something
different so i was like i mean if not
today to win maybe if i lose some more
games then
okay well that's good change is good we
had that big discussion on the show
today about flexibility and growth so
you can stick a feather in your cap or
stake the flag down that today you
changed and you beat someone who you've
competed with for so many years tell us
about this position uh when would you
feel confident that you were doing well
oh
i don't know there's so much happen in
this game
at some point i think i was doing very
bad but
when
when okay when i'm pinned and these
bishops are coming at me
but i think once i got
i think she misplayed at some point but
we've got a position here
yeah at this point i thought i was
thinking well um when i played
93 earlier and she took only three i
think maybe i should have played bishop
c1 because i realized like i didn't
realize which pieces i'm supposed to
exchange yeah if we go back one more
move
yeah maybe i should go bishop c1 here
i think i get away with it right like i
wasn't sure which pieces to exchange
here and then when after she took on it
and she went to f6 i was like okay my
bishop isn't great but i think at some
point i could have played that four oh
yeah definitely yeah
like it's just and then at some point
when i did and then the game went on i
was like oh my god i have a bishop on
the diagonal why am i not opening my
bishop why am i like doing all this
weird when you were here yeah
yeah quincy too you had f4 and knight g4
and uh you're kind of fun
yeah i mean quincy two is just such a
bizarre move because i just get hit by
roxy8 and then like i have to move again
so eventually she actually misplayed
the position and you were able to trade
off yeah i don't know why she didn't
take with the queen i touch yeah i think
the knight season is not a good yeah
after i took another and then i realized
she can't take with the queen i thought
just take with the rook
but even earlier i thought i had rook d6
at some point instead of knight d5 maybe
no hold on
no okay so knight d5 stair takes
yeah queen v1 knight c7
[Music]
takes roxy samsung and 96 right
which one 96 here right
bishop c196 yeah i thought and then
after i made a move and i thought i have
like rook d6 maybe that looks annoying
right absolutely
yeah
posting up again yeah and then my pieces
just coming with a temple
yeah but here um
yeah it's actually funny here after
everything that happened i didn't
realize that she has a minor and two
pounds for a rook that was just one pawn
then when i started calculating i was
like oh my god it's two pawns but here i
must be doing well right i'm just taking
her pawns i think i think her pieces are
a bit
awkward um
we thought her
oop sorry this was not the what she did
we thought she inverted
the move she made the wrong move we were
expecting after king h2 bishop e6 bishop
a5 we
thought she meant to play the move g5
here instead of bishop to d5 her
move in the game was bishop to d5 and
then
won
easily uh had she played g5 after that i
have queen d8 here no yes that's the
best that is the best because once
because then i take because when the
bishop goes to e6 i can take on e5 with
a rook and i hit her bishop right
so now if king f7 probably just defend
that pawn on a2 no but i have rook a1
here yes precisely
that's exactly right
because unfortunately for her
your
g4 just shut the game shut the attack
down
that way yeah i think i think she just
touches losing and she just tried to
one last
one last trick you seem to spend a
little extra time there were you worried
that you were blundering somehow maybe
yeah i think after my first round
masterpiece i have a lot of reasons to
think that
it's been a tough two rounds for sure uh
the first two rounds now
what does this do for the confidence
i mean
i don't know i still don't trust myself
a lot i mean it does not feel nice to
play something new and win a game and
just kind of feel like i can't play any
position and just play a little more
freely
so the rule the the takeaway from this
is listen to alejandro i mean that is
never the
[Laughter]
have we lost a one e4 player for life no
no no no no
i mean if you look at my database i
think it's like 100 it's only like one
night f3 maybe from title tuesday if you
like the first of night after is but
so you're going to return you'll have a
24 player so she's going to return to
her first left i was about to say you
know all of those e4 players all around
the world were crying out in anguish
come back we miss you well done all
right at least you can serve two or
three different ways you you see you can
play different kind of positions
congrats and good luck in the rest of
your games thank you absolutely well
done